Gabin est mort plier est mort d'allemand
est mort carnet est mort Albert Simonin
est mort Ventura est mort ils sont tous
morts mon carnet d'adresse c'est un
cimetière
c'est comme tu veux tu veux
pour aller ça va c'est pour revenir moi
je vais te dire j'ai pas de problème
parce que je vais à peu près 5 minutes
pour venir dans le restaurant
il travaille dans sa chambre
comme dirait Blondel
ça va ça va très bien sa première fois
que je viens ici
par jour
je pourrais avoir la carte s'il vous
plaît
je vais regarder ouais
je savais pas comment appeler le
restaurant alors je demande à trois
potes à moi 4 d'ailleurs Go et bio ou
des haricotine
alors il m'a dit il y a pas de problème
on te laissera à moi un mois et demi on
reviendra si c'est bien on le dira et si
c'est tard pour faire voir notre gueule
bah je sais c'est gentil et dis tu veux
appeler ça comment je l'ai dit au marché
noir en CDI c'est marrant j'ai oui les
gens ils ont dit on va bouffer ce soir
on peut marcher noir il y a Go qui me
fait oui c'est marrant mais t'aurais pas
les Juifs t'auras pas les résistances
t'auras pas l'école là non pas et puis
ça va il me reste rien aujourd'hui bon
toi tu as vraiment tu as vu dans les
tontons flingueurs tout ça dans tous ces
films il y en a plus des comme toi tu as
su que tu tiens tu es un survivant ça de
cette époque du cinéma
écoute j'ai fait cette année c'est le
dixième anniversaire de la mort de mon
pote Michel audierge
38 39 je voulais te voir cycliste et
puis moi j'étais je suis devenu
professionnel et lui il est devenu
porteur de journaux c'est perdu on s'est
retrouvé après et
quand cette année on a fait les
interviews sur le 10e anniversaire de la
mort Michel Audiard je crois pas que ce
n'est frais le
rédacteurs qui est là d'ailleurs il est
là
je vais attendre
la sixième fois il me téléphone pour une
interview sur Michel auder j'ai dit mais
tu es le sixième et me dit mais
tu vas en faire d'autres j'en ai fait 15
13 radio
à la rédaction quand tu dis faut faire
un truc trouver un proche de Michel
Audiard Gabin est mort plier est mort
d'allemand est mort carnet est mort
Albert Simonin est mort Ventura est mort
ils sont tous morts mon carnet d'adresse
c'est un cimetière le restaurant est en
même temps que tu es là en avant 77 avec
ma femme bonjour
ça va
et combien de temps que vous l'avez lui
27 ans 25 ans 27
non ça va non il est sympa
l'impression d'être un peu un monument
historique des fois quand même si des
fois oui c'est pas grave
il y a une femme qui me dit est-ce que
vous avez un modèle je suis dit non j'ai
pas de modèle les comédiens en général
ont un modèle je veux dire mais moi j'ai
pas de modèle je dis c'est étonnant je
veux dire pourquoi si je faisais un flic
il faut aller voir le commissaire lui
dire quand vous montez sur une enquête
est-ce que je peux aller avec vous
jusqu'au moment où vous me direz mais
maintenant c'est pas avec moi
tandis que là c'est pas facile puisque
je tue tout le temps et alors j'ai dit
alors la semaine dernière j'avais mes
amis qui fait un contraste un assassin
professionnel et je lui dis je vais
aller avec toi il me dit non je fais ça
tout seul alors elle m'a regardé
curieusement qu'à la fin je lui dis si
j'ai un modèle c'est qui du Charles
Vanel mais oui pourquoi parce qu'il a
fait son dernier film à 97 ans voilà
alors dis-moi ici quand même il y a un
peu certains soirs dans la salle il y a
quand même un peu les gendarmes et des
voleurs quand même oui bien sûr
j'ai des amis des deux côtés
ce truc qu'on peut reprocher c'est que
c'est pas noir et blanc quoi sinon
c'est vrai et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu